[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello overly worth that time yeah drop
us right in finally it happened
everybody went up happy Friday it's John
Luke and Ben you're in in the morning
it's little it feels like it's been
forever since you've been on a Friday
stream yeah busy and it was like I was
out on break you were out on break it's
been a lot we're here we're playing
Resident Evil it's not even called
resident evil it's just called project
resistant project resistance they have a
closed beta that went live late last
night yep so we're gonna check it out
yeah it's it's an interesting kind of
like asymmetrical setup yeah kind of
like I guess someone mentioned earlier
in the chat I saw we could probably put
it over oh sure yeah yeah let's just
bring her into the game kind of like
dead by daylight or the Friday the 13th
game except Resident Evil okay so I know
very little I've barely seen any I saw
that that initial reveal trailer with
the UI I looked real bad and rough this
game is still kind of looks but it's a
beta it's a beta it's a closed beta
sorry we should purpose that I guess you
could tell they're definitely reusing
those Resident Evil 2 assets to build
this game not that that's a bad thing I
mean that's very good-looking game yeah
I'm into it I played the tutorial in
like having a match as a mastermind
before this so we're gonna kind of learn
it as we go
I'm gonna cue up as a master mastermind
yeah I guess well we'll do mastermind
first so I can kind of embarrass myself
with that but the setup is you've got
this this guy who's kind of like doing
tests on subjects so they've got these
like courses set up for people to try to
cooperate and run through while a person
drops zombies and traps yeah not
available I said oh oh you're waiting
for Matt yeah we're queued up got it and
I was kind of apprehensive
after seeing like the gameplay reveal
and all that but after like playing it a
little bit I'm kind of I can kind of see
where it's going I think in theory a
Resident Evil game in this structure
sounds cool
I think the format fits well I mean you
know games like left for dead very much
influenced by Resident Evil and kind of
took that further with the co-op stuff
so idea of of this is sound I think it's
it's more I understand people's
apprehension because I think part of it
is that it's early access kind of what
they showed wasn't very polished and I
think a lot of people are kind of put
off by that and then also I think people
are just like where's the Resident Evil
late where is resident evil 3 remake and
and this is do we know who's making this
like what team cuz it's like I guess the
question is I never want to assume but
like I think there are people who make
that assumption that we got people
hanging out and talk in Japanese I love
it I don't know it sounded like French
between these two things is but I've
been sticking with we got the one man
you get to choose the the layout as the
mastermind - it's a kind of like that's
like I want a more zombie heavy one
here's where you'll find like the keys
to open the doors yeah yeah that kind of
thing I think I'll go with this one so
it's got a zombie okay and then you got
different like load outs for like words
and equipment and different enemies that
you can bring in
I like your guy there Daniel Wesker
esque yeah he's a real Wesker wanna be
looking dude but this is interesting
because I it really sets up kind of like
having different masterminds and like
Daniel specialty is bringing in the
tyrant from Resident Evil 2 so like what
if they do add Wesker and he brings him
like an Ouroboros thing and he's just
right like the idea is that there yeah
it's sort of going for that evolved vamp
like different monsters different
survivors oh this is great don't mute
that man no I'm I don't I wouldn't know
how to it's okay oh I actually think a
catastrophe might be like a PR person
for Capcom - how interesting that's
that's exam but yeah but what I was
saying is that I think there's I could
understand people's reservations if it's
like hey
game is if we're getting this game
instead of a remake but I'd like the
answer is like I don't know that right
like who's making it like I would
imagine like Capcom is still working on
Resident Evil if eight resident evil 3
remake so I like that you can do this
you can actually move in you want to get
in on that action yeah yeah chase them
around nice all the double slash awesome
hits get them hits I'll do these guys
have no idea what to do
you are already wrecking on the yeah
that's what you get for doing the
tutorial a little bit you get some they
get extra time when they they do things
won't make this guy a berserker because
why not and I'm gonna lock the door so
you spread your guys French yeah we got
a machine gun I'm gonna put mine here
looks like a resonable to asset flip
they made the re engine to make games
faster I mean that's just how game
development works you make an engine
that looks pretty good that way you
don't have to make a make another one
right you know you can streamline your
process from here I don't think that's
necessarily a bad thing
oh there we go Oh
is he down yeah he's down he already got
a guy down dang dude how long are is
each match uh so it's multiple parts
just like in the other don't help him up
stop no well one of the guys has either
shooting out my camera one of those
there want to appear a little bit
enhance that zombie that's right there
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay this is going a
lot better than I thought it would
there's a lot happening as Sony's this
is my first time seeing this game
there's just a lot going on right now
and put some zombie dogs around the
corner so I kind of like that you get to
do this like orchestration kind of thing
like it's there's a lot to kind of like
set up yeah this is interesting
the French rent this French act or we we
is on these zombie and I'm like why are
you playing as mastermind show that off
cuz that's far the most interesting its
most unique for sure I mean what will
hop in a survivor after but I think
there's a lot just of the UI's just a
lot yeah and I mean you know Whitby says
I really access so assuming they'll
change it it's a lot is really big but
man lock him in the bathroom though yeah
we got one of them yes
oh no that guy didn't get up in time I
can't believe this
don't walk that door oh there's a key
here I need to I need to fill this up
meats tough zombies leg-hold traps
beefed up beefed up beefed up from beef
mop beat the dog up I'm gonna I've
always wanted to be a dog president even
when I could finally do it
put a zombie dog in here I'm just I'm
just spamming at this point there's so
many things
put a line maybe oh I really don't want
I don't really like this French look
it's a player just seeing a zombie just
spawn in like that that's a good
question I see you with your guns not
today no so they get to the end of the
first area right they've lost a lot of
time and now you move on to the next you
know he's starting to grow on me a
little bit uh now he's getting worse I
hate him
I don't like him he's he's like it's
entirely like a resident evil kind of
it's very campy in a way that some it's
just I think it's the accent thing it's
like it's so bad yeah I think I'm almost
to be able to spawn in mr. X that that's
that's the fans what you want right yeah
see so they're just moving around trying
to make things work well there he is
let's bring him in like right here
yeah come here
oh I can't oh no they walked about they
closed the door on me hello hello
I move so slow I should oh no kill that
man
look crush the head crush his head yeah
Oh Tina the angle is kind of not yeah
this feels real small and Luke isn't
your name French but it is I'm actually
not French my my is the guy being French
isn't what bothers me is that it's so
like I am French over the tail wheelie
and I'm just like like stereo yeah it's
very like okay oh I can see where
everyone is back here they're all just
posted up outside the door what if I
just kind of like don't you do it
no I'm running out of time for I'm just
gonna leave them there
like trap okay so they can shoot out
cameras they can shoot them out they can
hack them every lock the store down here
know what I'm about to put a tough
zombie there a regular zombie in front
of him regen and I'm gonna beat them all
up watch they're not even gonna go this
way oh no they are walked through the
fire
do the thing well they've got like a
ghetto anything setup just punching you
yeah I'm dazed right now okay I saw that
kick come here
oh I got a liquor into that oh man this
is so what happens if they get to the
end do they like get to you and like
kill you
that'd be cool you just show up and
you're there in the chair
I'm gonna lock a store on this guy so
much of this game have you played so far
pretty much this okay haven't done too
much like get over here and try to get
out ahead of them put a like hold track
here and a landmine like right next to
it so I feel like I'm gonna have to come
down this way eventually because that's
the door out mmm zombie dog there you go
he walked right into it Sukie skeleton
brought up the Monster Hunter ice-born
trailer that just and today we're alike
you can play as Leon and Claire and then
mr. X is your handler and it looks ruled
real weird he's kind of really down with
it and gotten out of it to him looks
real bad
oh no he's got the electric gun
I want resident evil 3 not this I mean
there's still working on resin evil 3
supposedly right that's the that's the
thing apparently there's an easter egg
in here that teases resident evil 3 I
haven't seen it myself I heard people
saying that there's a thing for it oh my
dog went up here and got this person
I mean how comes not dumb they're
definitely making a resonable three
remain they're probably still work on
and they like like I don't think a lot
of people have this very perspective
that like after the success of those two
games they are they're like dropping any
sort of further development to make this
it's like definitely not like this is
probably a side project thing that a
different team is working for time while
they're working on am i doing this are
you getting it are you gonna do it I
think I'm doing it do it man
Oh get him are you like a cat mate girl
I think so wait I I think I think I won
[ __ ] then
hell yeah I'm nice good job
dang over that okay that man damn s rank
the best mastermind dude they're telling
me nailed it
alright while we try to survivor I want
through that success is like this foot
motive yeah
not sure what's happening I'm basically
spamming monsters around corner to try
and surprise ya it to be honest it is
very confusing snuggle stabbed you can
you can you can leave it's all I'm gonna
say yeah no need to be mean
it seemed to be full price I have no
idea yeah it feels feels a lot like it's
definitely kind of weird and buggy ish
no sure yeah it's a beta right like it
feels less buggy than I expected then
you expect it like it looks real jank
like everyone talks about that UI and
it's like yeah that UI looks like very
burly right like it's huge it's clearly
not like that it that is some like pre
assets like you're just trying to get
this game out there like I know I feel
like I want to see where it's gonna be
like either when it comes out or maybe a
couple of months after it comes out
after it gets more than it currently
it's gonna have like a single-player
campaign too so oh really interesting
that I do we know this is gonna be like
a full-price thing is is a pre really
like yeah but apparently a lot of these
characters have ties to characters from
outbreak oh okay there's a plate
outbreak like the story tie like it's
happening during Resident Evil 2 and
there are ties to outbreak in it hmm
but these are all just things that I've
kind of go exactly like what is 100%
true but this is all kind of like
speculation yes
when are we starting so right now we're
queued up to be survivors because we
just won around as masterminds
yeah it's I'm surprised how much I'm
enjoying it cuz I was as worried going
into it yeah like people asking for us
to start we're currently lost their eyes
right now can't see that we're cute if
that's what we covered the oh yeah yeah
yeah our our pip is covering it but if I
was to go to Hyuna game only you would
see that we are currently waiting for a
match I think people are one spot yeah
so we're waiting for a match guys we're
not just sitting here blindly it has to
queue up you think you'd get into a
survivor match quicker because everyone
will be trying to be masterminds but or
maybe that's why you're not getting into
a game quicker um but I don't I'm
curious I like it mhm and I think it'd
be a lot of fun playing with like a
group of friends right asymmetrical
multiplayer games aren't a thing you see
a lot - all right who am I gonna be Wow
someone's just on top of it who knows
how long I'd actually like continue play
it most games like this I I don't tend
to play them very long like left4dead I
played a fair amount but you know I
didn't play that game like religiously
the way I like some of my friends did
games like evolved I never really got
into like I kind of play him a couple
times
leave him dead by daylight I played
those games like a couple times and been
like yeah that was fun and I sort of
just was like I liked it by daylight but
I wish there were more objectives in it
I really really like the designs of the
monsters in it yeah I think the thing I
started getting the actual licenses for
the monsters they were knocking off
which was kind of funny that was that
was really funny yeah but I was still
around I really liked playing Friday the
13th and I'm really sad that they had to
stop yeah do they ever put out that
Jason X no you'll see they were laser
teasing in the models in there alone and
I'd say never actually released it Hales
weren't easy to start the game er start
matchmaking we already did dog yeah it
just takes a while it says it's it's
fine yeah yeah
yeah I think I don't like about that by
daylight was that if you wanted to play
like a private match with your friends
which is the way I would play that game
because it's like the fun right you you
couldn't level up at all yeah so you had
all the stuff say no no they didn't give
you any at least one way they gave you
every skill oh so when I play that first
maybe they changed that eventually
because when I played at first they
didn't give you any of the skills so we
would just be playing with basic starter
skills and it was like this kind of
stuff but still the hell yeah all right
man
do it up I love that it's just kind of I
don't I feel like this is probably a
better way to do operation Raccoon City
like this feels like it's it's a much
better playing operation Raccoon City
was I I played that game for like 50 or
60 hours really how damn bad why would
you not walk into that they're not even
looking at the camera anymore on the
other thing to remember too is you have
to still stand still they like get your
shots on things
okay so functionally it's very much like
as a survivor it's it sorry to remake
rules okay yep that's fine sometimes you
just gotta kick stuff okay so that's how
you tell that they're in there what that
he's on that he's got the the red bat
Rainbow six rules that's uh yeah I feel
like you guys wasting bullets yeah all
right so we gotta solve a puzzle I've
got a scanning ability that lets me
[Music]
we've got stuff out it seems and also
they've got a liqueur in there man you
got to get take care of that thing help
them up I think I don't know how I feel
about so these environments were very
claustrophobic which I feel like they
need to be for the way the level the
enemy design works right but when you
have these four players coming in it's a
lot this just seems like a mess oh my
god no why would you run away from me
okay oh boy anyway I'm gonna grab these
puzzle pieces now so they knew they knew
to go here
you need a you're already leaving don't
waste Randolph's looking at us yeah I
wonder if like the maps just need to be
like slightly larger to accommodate like
the four people cuz it just seems like
there's a lot happening at it's very
chaotic in a way that I don't think I
like Grenaa dime I'm not the one playing
so maybe I need to play it to kind of
get out better it doesn't make a lot
more sense when I when I've done the
quick-draw army shotgun it makes more
sense when I've got the when you did the
tutorial sure I guess I guess I'm saying
it's like just like running through it
it's not even that it doesn't make sense
is that there's just so many players
like on top of each other that it's it
looks like a lot to handle I kind of
want to do this I'm gonna do it
Donna pond says maybe map sets players
up a bit see that'd be cool
like oh do multiple objectives yeah you
have to split up maybe like teams of two
that would be cool that something that
maybe yeah it takes more advantage of of
that we've got people running up here
oh hello you know what it's kind of
weird
I've noticed your you're missing is
you're not getting as much of that like
reaction on the zombies
yeah like Lego that's like an online
thing or yeah just the way it has to
work because something I really liked
about present evil to remake was when
you would hit the way zombies would
react like the way when you shoot them
the animation stuff it it made all of
that it's it's a lot more fast paced and
I think that might kind of like I don't
know if this is supposed to be a
survival horror situation no but but I
think it that was a thing that I found
so satisfying about the combat and
Resident Evil 2 remake that you're not
getting here at all and I wonder if that
is yeah is it the case where they can't
do it because of the pacing of it
oh those credits because I feel like
there's a constant want to push forward
sure you can't like stop and choose your
shots yeah like honestly it'll probably
be better in this single-player because
you're sharing another person constantly
I mean I think what I would would
personally what I would really like is a
game where you you almost don't even
know that the mastermind is there you
know what I mean yeah like imagine
playing like Resident Evil 2 and then
light and it just plays like that it
feels like it's just a scripted thing
but there is a player actually
controlling everything right and you you
uh like I don't like that music like
this is very much like you know that
there's another player there and you
know they're constantly dropping and
stuff this is mr. X kind of sounds like
it it definitely sounds like
first aid screen the other room ammo
here multiplets he's probably off trying
to murder the other two people don't
people are asking how how you get
invited into this beta how did you get
in I just signed up for it on the
website okay
right after they announced it it's a
music hold on I hear oh oh hello there
it is didn't do that quick-draw
you know the I wonder something bout
seeing this like teenage girl in the
hoodie like revolver ocelot II I'm just
kind of famer in that hand hammering
that fan you know it's really funny
I don't hear
now I see a couple people saying that
they're more interested in what the
single player for this game would look
like yeah that's I would hope it's it's
not just this but single player you know
like I would I would hope there's more
to it than that but I don't know I'm not
really sure what the overall scope and
vision of this game really is I feel
like they've said so little about it
also she's supposed to have like a
hacking ability and I don't think I just
may just don't have sell things all the
Lightning Hawk though for the shotgun
though you know maybe I'll do a shotgun
man do shotgun put the lightning hog a
sledgehammer I do like how you get like
better and better weapons as you go to
see it a couple people say that they
feel like maybe this should have instead
just been like a multiplayer addition to
Resident Evil 2 rather than like its own
game I mean I think it's an interesting
idea I didn't the problem is more that
like how many people would buy that
right how many people would buy like a a
multiplayer Edition for Resident Evil
almost like a year after it's out I feel
like it would've had it been out
launched to do it so I understand them
making it its own separate thing instead
I've already fallen behind anybody is
just I realized that uh yellow words in
this gaming just a buff that's kind of
open they do a little bit more
I'm gonna join you let's let's go here
let's do this thing it's okay I'll hit
the switch Oh
or you can take the long way up
someone's getting hit oh these are the
things we had to destroy in the tutorial
okay oh you're one of your guys down on
my way back down - hold on buddy how did
he get killed
I don't know but they've probably
crawled a long way I got you just hold
on that was a really good try did you
thank you I'm gonna drop this probably
stick together
oh let me get out of here you're a bat I
did you're a bad sit here it's okay this
is fine this is okay push him away mr.
axe don't do it somebody wants to know
why the timer is red and blue like what
that mean I think it represents the
defender and the attacker yeah oh god
save me
oh that's fine
yep I get crushed on now so you just
teleport back to the last checkpoint
if you die which is kind of nice but it
takes away time 30 seconds of time is
huge I forgot a really good angle on
that yeah so yeah yeah that blues like
your overall health pool right you're
like oh that's your time there's time
you guys use you've lost a lot yeah we
need to find more of these objective
bits which is my main thing nope got
better
now you guys aren't doing that higher
neither I need get back up top there's
one of the things up on there and that
the tyrants got to be going away soon -
sometimes I should have brought back
outbreak curious in a game that was more
in the vision of outbreak I kind of
thought it was gonna be outbreak and I'm
a little sad it wasn't that's what I
thought too
originally I was ago they're gonna do
like a new version outbreak that'd be
really rad like with the RT - kind of
because this sort of operate was was
using the assets of Resident Evil 2 and
three kind of made a co-op II resin evil
experience jeez I think I would've doing
outbreak had that thing I was talking
about where it feels like a
single-player game like classic resin
evil but just with other players I would
have really liked something like that
personally and a solid business what is
happening everything is on fire
you're the thing that's gonna kill us
okay lady now to me you guys are
definitely not gonna win yes
nice
Oh No he's definitely gonna kill me or
not I'm crawling okay
now you're dead you're dead dead oh
you're at negative 15 seconds Ben you
can still do it we're in over time
because we're doing something I guess oh
that seems really rough for a survivor
that's why I was trying to like maybe
not play as much of them because I don't
have a headset on and I feel like
communication was probably a really good
yeah that's compliant cuz like the man
when I was yelling into the void shoot
the liquors that are trying to you know
what you made it a minute longer than
that other team did when you were the
mastermind it's true so you wanted a
mastermind again or do you wanna be
survivors well maybe I'll just go back
and forth like yeah swap swab back and
forth and I'll try out a different
survivor when we come back to it yeah
I'm I'm digging this actually like just
as as a weird aside kind of thing
Raccoon City is a way better game yeah
oh just what I've been playing in this
in this beta
I think the beta for this game plays
better than operation Raccoon City
though I appreciate once you get the one
gun that actually does damage in the
operation of a city that that's when
that game makes sense but I appreciate
like all of the cool like fan services
stuff if they let the yellow dude play
so he'll quit bitching am i bitching a
lot I don't think was complaining a lot
who's ready for Last of Us - I'm excited
to play it I'm kind of like I'm one of
the weird people it's like super
lukewarm on most of us like I I love
playing the first one yeah way up until
the end and then I didn't like the end
and then I was kinda like the combats
kind of not the best but it's not bad
for a Last of Us yeah so I'm excited to
play the second one I liked it a lot at
IU I'm gonna replay cuz I was thinking
about this at the time when I beat it I
was like man that's maybe one of my
favorite games ever dang and I've played
it twice
and and but it was pretty like I played
it once and I played it again when I
came out and I'm ps4 but I haven't
played it in a really long time and I
feel like I haven't thought about in a
while so I'm kind of curious going back
like am I still gonna feel the same way
about it that I did when it first came
out yeah I what it's done and I it's
really impressive technically and Sharaf
the story is again I really enjoyed it
all the way up until oh yeah oh shoot
it's Daniel Daniel's in the chat forgot
we got Daniels on deck oh man I love it
see make sure to go into oh my god we
got some some cool story backstory going
on
now we're explaining his eye his
portrait is so like Wesker wannabe yeah
yeah
see multiplayer and last VOSA yeah I
like that I actually really like it I
there are people who got very good at it
I liked it a lot I have friend of mine
who just got obsessed with a key I think
he got every achievement I think if I
were to choose between that in uncharted
Baltic where though I'd probably take on
charge
oh I referred in front of the door cuz
they're gonna get up there and realize
it's locked
some alone emmalin's like oh you don't
like the ending the Joel's decision at
the end yeah I wasn't a big fan of it
but I guess I liked it a lot it's I
think it's been purposefully meant to
kind of be like a polarizing yeah like I
could see what it was but I was alright
we're gonna go inside they walked right
into the landmine perfect discounts
going tough Sambi right up the side of
the door this is working out pretty well
the dog right in front of them drop this
guy I know you're being hacked got a
machine gun that I can hit him with as
soon as they come through that door
because I forgot to lock it
let's get a crawling zombie right around
here sound that that man just made and
so just as one map so far better good I
can't spawn it anything avenues and
zombies just gunning them I've been
getting a lot of gun cards
that's all let's do that I'm gonna play
as a zombie dog oh no I can't control
him you can't control the dogs be kind
of cool
maybe they'll add that in maybe that's
not ready yet thank you you're being
hacked up all over someone's on top of
their their hackings man I can't he see
Marshall says when multiple times is the
mastermind best of survivors it's a mess
it it seems like it's really done it
seems really hard as the survivors to
win give me that discount time to go
leave I'm not gonna waste my points
I don't know if points carry over
actions that'll be an interesting thing
to see ok yes let's get some some tough
zombies hidden around all but the dealer
though I need to close these doors he
does I don't I hate it I hate it so much
oh boy dog dog right here and a landmine
right in front of the door Carrington I
think what Ben didn't like was just the
choice the not choice that's kind of
made at the end and the direction that
went in I guess I'm trying to keep it a
little vague and I think some people
that I respond but I'm keeping a vague
cuz I people want to play last this one
continuous French or German oh he's
definitely French Germans don't go
wee-wee at the end of every sentence
neither do Frenchmen to be fair ok doo
doo doo
where'd you go hey Jim come here come
here
Oh lock the door
crab sees Daniel from House of the Dead
oh man that'd be way better
what if this was just House of the Dead
I'd be more into it in like a weird yeah
yeah house they should make another
house of the Dead it really should what
was the last one they made what was it
that like exploitation yeah kind of and
then they made the typing version of it
yeah
overkill how's the Dead overkill
hello come here
we're just go in a town howdy
yeah came into the wrong room
oh my god
Ben mr. X is real fun to play an average
Wells is here where are they I need to
stalker right there over there
we're almost out of time with them
coming I know you got two seconds one
second ah we did some damage all right
let's use a discount you can't pass
through walls not cool that would be
cool if he could buff one walls maybe
certain parts of the map do have walls
that you can bust through though that'd
be rad yeah I'd be into that you get to
pick different ones
let's get that regen zombie there it's
good to Sami dog down the hallway a
little bit machine gun time
the machine guns way better than I
thought it would be all right where's
this last guy at supply zombie has made
it there yet oh he's way back let's
build this hallway up since everyone's
got to come back let's put this here
sure
let's close this door up let's get
another zombie dog butt down here so
it's gonna see I think that's more
interesting is like pre-emptive planning
rather than yeah we're just doing it in
the room they're in on the fly oh man
yeah see that's what I'm talking about
that's awesome more that like I like the
idea of like pre setting up a room like
maybe give like 30 seconds to like
really stuff or something yeah that'd be
pretty cool hi there you're mine now
Oh God she lasts a while she's got some
help doing it oh she's got a night what
do you got there thanks that guy anytime
I'm here for it I couldn't make a dive
Dorrie
try almonds what other parlor tricks do
you know generator
okay sure tough zombie yeah let's put
them right in front of you where you
punching crawling zombie right behind
you sure yes
no pain the perfect machine for this
event
hello
well I appreciate that you can cleave
everything that's real good
do you have ammo are you gonna get them
before they even get through the first
area I don't think this guy's got me
just unlocked in the corner
yeah but they also have 13 seconds left
so you just got to continue to be
stunlock for the next eight seconds the
other guy isn't he's right there he's
trying to get a shot oh no man ah dude
it's fine it's fine
13 seconds Shh really close and we got
an armored zombie cuz this is the room
where everything gets wild though
because you get to call mr. X in about
now there is got just like that all
right I'm gonna put a foothold trap
right here call I'm gonna put an armored
zombie we're all gonna have trouble
trying to hit him and then while that's
happening I'm just gonna call in mr. X
later on after I boost these guys come
on it's a little bit more I don't know
if that actually maybe
that there I'll put a landmine in the
middle of this and while everything
regenerates let's bring them in hello
dad's home let's go
Oh God down there hit the button though
do the other button
Oh auntie they got two seconds left
again people are infected people are
dying people are getting crushed I don't
know how they could have recovered from
that oh man so I go over here whoa be
the master minds really fun
I seem to way more fun than being the
survivor is I gotta be honest there's
also like that kind of like weird like I
really like being able to play as the
monsters and Resident Evil that I sure
sure this is fun it's a fun twist let's
try it survivors again see I'd love to
see a survivor group make it but that
could be a little rough I really think
that the thing that you need is the
communication I think that's what really
kind of right holds it back and I'm not
helping by not having a headset on but
it's just kind of how it goes yeah all
right so we're queued up cool doing it
yeah I can imagine like just playing it
with friends and being like oh God is
surprised for you in the next room and
they're like oh no what is it what are
you gonna do yeah it sounds fun like
there's something kind of like fun and
kind of devious about it
now how many my maps right now it's only
the downtown one in the beta but I don't
know how many there will be when it
comes out I assume there'll be a lot of
like stuff based off the president evil
- I want like a good like a street
street-level map right I want them I
want a little bit more variety I mean
granted it's just the one map so far we
haven't even seen it all the way through
this beta but yeah yeah yeah it'd be
down flow be Dan Daniel says being
Daniels always fun that's that's good
yeah
there we go all right I'm gonna go with
Valerie again because she's supposed to
be able to hack things auto-aim walk
okay it's survival instincts so you
think I'm the same girl yeah yeah girl
Valerie because I think she's supposed
to be able to like hack stuff didn't
seem like you're able to do it either
way she's really good at finding things
or me you know what now they're saying
January's the hacker shoot I guess I'll
mix it up a little play is the the beat
beat him up
it's a boxer so we could've right try to
hit on as many of those seams think you
guys are having a tough time enjoying
the game well bet seems to be enjoying
I'm having a good time yeah yeah I think
um I mean you guys are also why I'm
watching it with you guys as well but
I'm watching it I think it's kind of a
mess it might be one of those games
where you just gotta fun to watch you
gotta play it rather than watch it cuz
just watching it I'm like yeah after
this you want to try being the
mastermind a little bit maybe I didn't
do this tutorial oh so like I don't know
I could walk you through it all tutorial
I'll live to play okay let's try that it
won't be too bad we'll have a good time
with it and you've got tons of room to
kind of mess around with okay sure
tutorial eyes me through that through
the the masterminds see winner thinks
I'm pretending to have fun I'm actually
liking joining and I didn't expect to
sure bad yeah let's just get a second
melee weapon right off right off the bat
q by for all the bats that's right here
I'm gonna work through this 2x4 first
though well this person's got got shots
on deck
so I feel like I'm gonna be much more
like up in everything like kidding right
that's kind of your character right yeah
come here you are already moving through
the door I want to get behind see it
like this wood wood things already
almost broken oh there we go yes so she
is the hacker nice ah oh you got trapped
now I understand why people have stuck
in it
I realize it now I've had to do it
myself
I forgot puzzle to solve pieces to find
we do my job
oh geez
I can just punch things I forgot let's
do it nothing about him punching this
liquor yeah maybe I shouldn't do that
Oh God you got your ability or your
super punch I don't know maybe use that
try doing these kind of like oh it's
just a regular punch
your your your l1 r1 yeah yeah there we
go that's what I'm here for I don't see
that thing marked anywhere so I'm
wondering if we've
oh it's in the next room cool I hit it
you just kind of danced a bit I'm gonna
try --cz on there no just get in the
thing there we go okay not to worry
about that little bit
I should probably buy some healing stuff
realizing that I'm a character that goes
up in the fur on you all the time
bye bye bye - have any cool melee
weapons now I can get sledgehammer yes
please
I forget that I'm gonna heal up or no
that's cool I got it
no more no non-stock I guess we all we
all bought it out
that's here oh yeah I think we share
credit system so that's we're not like
share credits but the pickups get him do
what I'm doing it he's he's doing me
there we go there you are
you got a sledgehammer
oh man I'm feeling that Friday
sleepiness yeah I gotta tell you it's
it's all good
maybe maybe trying the thing I'll give
you that that little bit of a boost me
because I the thrill of the thrill of
messing with people
it's that's what it is this is just
trolling other people that's of course
you love this oh my god it all makes
sense
we figured it out it was chorus of
course Ben loves it
what's for lunch today guys all right I
know steak what I heard
Oh God he said you're already dead I
activated my punch ability and he said
you're already dead they know what
they're doing Oh
dead I'm already dead look out it's it's
a real angry zombie and try to block
them of my body for you
good good using those those walls I like
it heal me she looks familiar
I think she might be related to one of
the outbreak I'm not familiar with that
just more like she looks like a like
after something like an actress oh I
don't know like her face looks so
familiar to me like reminds me of
someone and we're out of here I want to
go back to the fact that when he did his
super bills usage or or is that that's
that's still getting me yes this game is
clearly going for a more tongue-in-cheek
tone as may be the right way to put it
like it's trying to be more silly which
I guess kind of like you know fits the
like the game playing stuff nothing
about it's very like scarier spooky so I
guess maybe going for more silly is is a
way to do it I'm gonna buy two baseball
bats and some hand grenades
okay
here I hear those those claws out there
let me go I'm waiting for mr. X to show
up because I know that's that's how I
did it last time
oh my baseball bat isn't here oh that's
oh no also not yep closed beta everyone
are you not actually I can't tell if
you're hitting them or not but you did
an animation take us up here so I'm
doing bad so far yeah I think we're kind
of sticking together which is common all
right I got my bat out okay maybe an
hour work who is this oh oh I know who
this is
never mind get out of the way I'm more
important that I don't want to die I'm
streaming here how do you even deal with
mr. axe at that point I think you
probably right we just run away unless
you've got something heavier Oh
he's having some ragdoll fun over there
don't come towards me oh he's here no no
no that she's broken man like it's cool
and you're the mastermind but when
you're the survivor you're just sitting
there being like dude like all right
let's do it
Oh perfect timing
and then a dog shows up I don't know if
hitting buttons actually does anything
no that's not what I want that healing
spray that's literally right up there
let me go to infection suck hmm Oh God
use did he just yell I know kung fu what
is happening in this video game actually
the Audion no anymore
[Music]
I'm gonna get ice we're gonna do it but
forget this dog at some point do you try
and hit that dog in that melee since I'm
so help my friends know punch these
things let me out of here behind you
thing spawning oh he's got him all
beefed up go for a special ability this
doesn't seem like it's that's strong
yeah or at least like there's no
feedback that you're like I can't tell
if you're doing anything I guess that's
what the numbers are for right but it's
kind of I was talking about about how
resin evil two had that like very good
animation feedback that like this game
is kind of lacking right now
I'm just gonna crawl now I guess I came
to help my friends my friends didn't
help me oh man you guys are doing pretty
well this part so far I was kind of
hoping you'd make it make it out of this
area cuz no one's gotten past this part
in our playthrough so far yeah well
they're the keys over there or the next
objective is over there on the other
side of the room so worst case maybe
I'll spawn back in and I'll be able to
again or make a run at it yeah but the
problem is that you lost much time
because he died yeah oh yeah a lot of
time take this
oh no I couldn't even make it through
the door ah man that's a bummer I feel
like I was probably the best one you've
seen though for that it was the best
runner he's seen but I'm bummed that no
one's gotten any further than that
yeah be for it that's not bad
oh yeah you want to try to be into
masterminds I'll get a try
so uh it's it's kind of uh to go into
the map which is what you have to do a
lot and you press the touchpad okay and
that's how you pick different cameras
hmm - jump - it's kind of on like a like
a card system it's got the like each
card has a point right value assigned to
it and dropping things it took me a
second to realize it but you move it and
kind of face it with the left stick okay
and then you drop it with X got it so
you can kind of like move it to a corner
then face it like a certain way that
kind of thing
yeah those are the kind of main things I
I could think of right off the top of my
head all right I'm ready yeah yeah let's
go wait for this match to load in you
want to call it after this one
you think yeah I'm down yeah there's
still some stuff going on and I feel
like I feel like we've seen it I think
I've kind of seen everything I was sort
of hoping for the to get a run the
survivors going further but if that's
not gonna happen then I'm okay if we can
we can close it after after this one
yeah so it I playing more I've come down
to realize I may be the the mastermind
is just more fun because you don't have
to cooperate with anyone oh for sure
right like I'm really wondering how much
more I'd enjoy the survivor side if I
were actually like playing with people
and like coordinating
yeah
either gonna call it and there's only so
much we can do other than try to like
make more runs in making it yeah I've
heard but not much of a reason to yeah
there's not too much going on that's
outside of what we've already shown but
oh I I'm coming away from this more
optimistic I think sure I think I'm more
I don't know it's so early it's like
hard to tell but I I guess like I mean
I'm about to play so maybe I'll have
different opinion but from what I've
seen nothing about this feels unique or
different enough that I'd want to really
invest my time in it personally and the
the single-player stuff is interesting
that's the thing I need to know what
that is but like everything I've seen so
far I'm like well like I don't know
nothing about it
screams resident evil and the ways that
I like Resident Evil and then it's like
it hasn't done anything particularly
unique to this like style of game that
I've seen so far and then you know on
top of it just kind of being real janky
which is that's more like it's a closed
beta like when you play it I feel like
it's less janky than it looks exactly
well that's the thing we were saying
yeah yes cyborg brings up a good point
that where's Barry put Barry in this
game yeah there you go that no no Barry
no bye that would be blob better so
that's right stand way I'm wondering if
maybe this is just a whole world
oh why a hundred percent belief that it
that is absolutely like the this is
clearly a a side thing they're doing I
think to have something in between
getting Resident Evil eight and
resonable three because that is 100%
coming before anyone gets carried away
sub work man just sits you guys saying
this is another umbrella core no nothing
is as bad as umbrella core was the
umbrella core expert when when I also
played like 20 hours of that but in the
the survey to apply for this beta
they're like what resident
games if you played and had experience
with and they list all of the games
bought umbrella core Capcom doesn't even
want to acknowledge umbrella core it's
trail no this game is is leagues better
than umbrella core it's is not even a
comparison yeah
waiting for this match to load in for a
for minutes in four minutes four minutes
waiting still on the way
still still going operation Raccoon City
I put up with but there I remember
specifically there being only one gun
that was viable to do anything yeah
which was probably the biggest problem
with it I had there we go
see it Daniel gets to pick the map you
get to pick a preset I like three cuz it
has more zombies right off the bat I'll
try that one okay I'll go down then
you'll really good to mess with any of
this because there's nothing unlocked
I know unlocks okay oh yeah when you
press triangle when you ready I'm ready
let's try it hope you guys love you too
Andrew and I hope you guys are having a
good Friday and I hope you're yeah do
some cool stuff during the weekend
what's everyone got a play on the
weekend yeah there's so many things to
choose from there's a lot of things
I'm gonna finish control probably or I'm
gonna play some more destiny I'm gonna
play a lot of destiny I think I'm feel
like I'm gonna be able to wrap up
control maybe tonight so that'll be easy
destiny control I'd like to do more
gotta finish Link's Awakening yeah yeah
I'm doing a slow burn on that one it's a
short game but I've been taking it
taking it slow nice you know nice pace
played a bit of this game it's really
good starts yeah it's it's so the first
thing you want to do is you want to lock
that door okay
that's good and you got crawling zombies
which are put down on the ground if you
want to go back out you click okay I can
just do that okay it's like you press
press X on whatever you want to drop in
so like on that zombie that's over on
the side just to practice what do I
dancer press X and then now you can move
with the left stick if you want to like
change how it spicy behind the car so
like a lunge out it's got it got it it's
like I want to put a thing there yeah so
you got the trap there not change your
camera you gotta use the oh I don't know
you could do it that way I thought I
mean the maps probably just gonna remind
myself where I am okay so so this is
where you can start
building up the next room because the
doors locked right and they're still
fighting the stuff out there let's get a
zombie dog and the other thing to
remember is you've got the that boost
boost I'm probably gonna use it right
now and then you've got that machine gun
to boost boost boost get the machine gun
yeah you can kind of like start to see
how some of the cards like work together
and even like we'll put a trap here or
so they walk out they're gonna be too
busy looking at the zombies is like
right something kind of figure out over
time right yeah and I do like like the
build of like power kind of feels good
from place to place it's like right now
you've got all these basic zombies and
you've got a lot of kind of gadgets but
then you start bringing in like mr. X
and you got liqueurs and you've got you
even have to do anything for him
this game engines fantastic do what
happened it can evil are they finished
yeah they finished until until the next
resident evil thing happens they gotta
come in here right I think so
so you've got all the all the keys and
stuff marked on your map I can't like
shift from room so it's just for that
area okay I see it's kind of I'm wasting
that I like I like bring up the map cuz
like just get a better sense of what's
going on I want to like pimp this
ramallah basically zombie dogs and
you'll have that machine gun that you
can use just like that
and you got a grenade launcher special
card drop that dog on him yeah they
thought they were gonna get away and
they walked right into the into the the
landmine and fell over I just there are
a lot of things it's gonna get up and
he's gonna walk right into that the idea
is that this is just let me play like i
get i get i get this being fun like it
is fun to just be like I'm just gonna
drop that there and then you're not
gonna be able to do anything all the
stuff if you want to because why not
yeah why not they go all that's boosted
now put a zombie outside because they're
about says you know yeah get another
right there or you can lock the door -
if you if you drop
Oh
okay well you've got the you've already
got like a liquor card I do appreciate
them to let you just spawn stuff like
out in the open
yeah yeah for them to get up and it's
definitely like they didn't get my
camera okay oh yeah that's a lot of time
knocked off it's not bad so I'm
wondering if the single player will be
more like outbreak that's my hope right
the regen zombie is pretty good I like
them a lot they're fun to control
I go to the end to lock the door that
one right there ooh so I'm already
getting like the like I know my layout
and I know the map and I'm like oh yeah
if I move up here and close this door
I'll know the bill they'll get routed
through this way if I put something here
right and then you get some mr. X so
that's your I can find people through
walls your punches on square and get to
do the charge with circle and your grab
is triangle and you get to block your
face yeah yeah yeah okay he's he's
getting God so the zombies heal from
eating - which is a
that's someone's definite PSN name ah
that grab is kind of yeah that's a
tricky one that's a tricky one
I can maybe grab him here nope I can't
get some good hits all right not as good
as I want it within but I took out two
people yeah I'm getting the hang of it
okay so that's the door right it's open
yeah someone's opened it so you can lock
it again so but the the room they're
gonna be going to is that is this one
right so I wanna go over here okay
just lock the doors put put like a
liquor inside of there look around the
corner because the the security zombie
already has a whole bunch of armor and
they've also got another incentive to go
in there so that's like to Gabby I want
to get a booster booster
everyone's getting the boosts
so they're gonna have to go in there at
some point if they're about to
[Music]
what you're gonna keep it in this room
like you're they're not even gonna make
the mix air dang I was doing that well
[Music]
you got got some really good like just
rooms like that was dang alright let's
see how do I get like a better idea of
it when you actually like yeah yeah your
hands off for sure I do like this aspect
of the game yeah it's pretty fun dang
kid where you came in and said the best
time on your first try
alright so that part I get the survivor
stuff seems so janky I don't really know
I feel about that so we're gonna call
right actually that doesn't seem right
yeah I feel like like I should have
gotten a higher bonus cuz I I kill them
faster yeah that was that was Resident
Evil project resistance I think it's
just called Project resistance for now
I'm assuming it'll eventually have a
different name but that's a weird that's
a weird name for your final game an
in-progress thing yeah exactly so yeah I
mean it seems I'm pretty mixed on it I
definitely understand the mastermind
stuff now it's fun I don't know if the
survivor stuff looks all that great it
seems real janky which it's really
access I get it but also I don't know if
there's any so far there's nothing here
that's really making me be like yeah I
want to play it yeah I I feel more
optimistic now but I'm definitely still
kind of like just more balancing yeah I
now find some way that maybe it is just
the communication thing maybe that's the
only missing part for making survivors
maybe maybe well anyway that was
resonable project resistance we stream
every Friday not will you and me stream
every Friday yeah specifically when we
can but yeah we stream every weekday
from 11:00 p.m. Pacific I was trying to
say Pacific and I said p.m. I'm tired
it's fries okay it's been a heck of a
week thanks for watching guys we really
appreciate it
I don't know if that works anymore I
think it does hey there it is we've done
it if yeah I don't know I don't know
is there anything interesting coming up
this weekend video wise we got going on
next episode of true fiction on game
overs it's gonna be on nightmare in Elm
Street our new show on GameSpot universe
you guys should check that out like you
said it's about Nightmare on Elm Street
you haven't seen that or the other two
episodes which is about Godzilla and
about twin geeks
they're very good it's a great show she
definite definitely definitely was
highly recommend highly recommend it
other than that I know that we're gonna
have a bunch reviews coming in early
next week
destiny Ghost Recon all that good stuff
so check that out have a good time and
enjoy your weekend everyone
[Music]